Olivia holy repeat after me hi Olivia I'll
give you Greg Rachel
sorry I want to be funny if I did
citizens of the reject Nation we're going
to call this segment movies you can't watch
without your wife or else she'll get mad at
you any couple who's been in a long-term relationship
can relate Hey Olivia misses Alba oh God I
was hoping you wouldn't do that we would call
you vice president no my bad first lady vice
president I'm learning what political hierarchies
are nothing all in your beer it happens man
jeez you complain when John disappointed out
yeah you've got something all in your beard
anyway guys we're gonna watch The Little Mermaid
today we love the original one before we go
into any of that something that we did want
to talk about uh Olivia and I we have four
cats ourselves but within the past month we
have been fostering five additional cats because
we're insane these five cats that we've been
fostering won't go in any details but uh long
story short they came from a really really
bad you know domestically violent home when
taking care of them we got them properly bathed
right ones we got you know spayed and neutered
even been potty trained lately they're great
uh just really really love them just right
now though you know for these five cats we
gotta you know Siamese once Dash and Asher
Aspen Wren and mama who looks like the baby
but she's really mama and what's her actual
name you're gonna call her mama this whole
time Laura really really do love them and
right now we have been actively looking for
people to adopt them um if you can adopt all
at least adopt like one or two of them so
there's a link in the description box and
pin comment for the rescue site you would
have to go through the rescue site in order
to adopt them as much as we love them just
with the space that we have we know that they
deserve a better home right now a place where
they can be properly cared for and loved if
you are interested or know someone who's interested
please ask and sincerely if you can spread
the word and uh help help these guys find
a home because they absolutely deserve it
and they are lovely truly lovely animals and
we're gonna miss them but uh anyway I'm gonna
segue us now to the video at hand leave a
like on this video if you're excited for Little
Mermaid I've heard good and bad things but
we are gonna form our own opinion and anyone
who knows my wife she is known to be the most
brutally honest person in the world and by
the way she has been vastly instrumental behind
the scenes and ask anyone who comes on this
channel John especially would know she has
helped out behind the scenes numerous times
and plain and simple she does not get enough
credit and I don't know whose fault that is
but they deserve to be punished yeah this
double truck has a lot to do behind the scenes
okay also full-length reaction watching long
reports where you single with your own copy
of Little Mermaid if you already have one
available for our super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you to all who have joined
and shown your support but if you have to
make a decision between helping the cats or
joining the patreon help the cats please let's
watch this movie people
it's a gorgeous opening shot I feel like we're
about to hear Neil deGrasse Tyson narrating
this or that one from the BBC old British
guy
the Mermaid has no tears and there before
she suffers so much more I know a lot of Hans
Christian Anderson's work it sounds like she's
probably suffered
that the original author yeah oh [Music]
my God what a horrible
interesting so they're all just they know
they're hunting a mermaid right now I think
they're thinking it's like those deep sea
tales that fishermen and Pirates tell each
other a mermaid use your eyes a poor dolphin
do not hurt that dolphin they tell you this
is when we see King calls his will make Jordans
together to learn men to that day it's not
what they say tail [Music]
we're going home tonight pay attention I need
you to be more careful
Crimson oh here we go show me what I'm here
for show me the things I know
[Music] look at these realistic fish that
these overpaid VFX are I was gonna say clearly
it's not real but okay we know that Disney
screws over their VFX artisan [Music]
better than the flash hey everything is better
than the flash these days
my man trident [Music] keep a fish Daughters
of the Seven Seas I welcome the news from
all of your Waters oh Halos for good Tamika
and gaspia Indira they're clearly not all
from the same mom is that Jessica Chastity
I don't think so Karina
Rose cereal Ariel I told you Sebastian says
audio I told you Sebastian I reminded her
about the Gathering just this morning what
Mark I want crustacean do
yle he's cute I like him he's adorable you
know we aren't supposed to be this far from
the palace Ariel let's go back oh this is
a little unsettling
I think we've gone far enough look at the
details on her skin they even have like little
scales that's cool I've never seen that one
real wait for me you know I can't swim that
fast yeah he's small I know a small boy he
was fat as hell in the freaking cartoon he
was a little chunky flounder he must have
used the ship for battles or something yeah
let's get out of here getting cold fins no
and you can stay out here and watch the Sharks
all right what I mean he is still cute he's
very cute he's very adorable when she did
a little boo-boo on it I was like adorable
be cool to have a talking fish I want to poop
a fish
[Music] I'm King flounder Lord
it is very adorable
will he relaxed it's just a reflection that
is great because animals can't tell their
Reflections no
fish are friends not food I know Bruce no
Bruce don't do it would sharks be afraid of
mermaids I don't know if this happened in
the cartoon so I know it did considering her
father is the king of the ocean
[Music] hide hide baby flounder hide
[Music]
yes leave that shark there to die that's cool
too the Sharks can't talk in this world for
some reason so it's just gonna die down there
what are you doing don't mind me I was just
grabbing a snack that's right they got Aquafina
yeah I forgot any idea what this is oh oh
oh oh it's a dingle hopper still funny humans
use these babies to style their hair your
father still won't let you go to the surface
huh no it's forbidden he thinks all humans
are are various they are my name's who's a
rock the Gathering the King Triton's daughters
minus one I thought it was gonna kill me yeah
sorry Scuttle gotta go yeah yeah all right
sweetie I think the Sebastian is Lafayette
from uh Hamilton David Dixon oh I think so
I don't know what a shame is
to invite Angie Ursula to the party again
oh this is gonna be a lot sadder in live action
I'll tell you that much I know look at me
Madness all right Melissa McCarthy doing doing
pretty good I may have finally found Daddy's
weakness an ethnicity of a woman he hasn't
been with yet [Laughter] just like your mother
I am her daughter yes foolish enough to be
taken with the human world if you would just
try to understand try to understand you long
enough but as long as you live in my ocean
you'll obey my rules oh a man we've all had
those talks at authoritative quality I listen
to you oh yeah I would my aerial needs constant
supervision all the time day and night and
you're just a crap to do it I am just decrypted
no wait that's not what go yes your majesty
a lot of things definitely move better in
the actual film than in the trailer like Sebastian
really just creeped me out in the trailer
but it really looks really looks really great
here yeah I appreciate that they actually
make them a little animated yeah it's like
a good blend between this is what it looks
like in real life but it's also animated real
life crabs are cute though too they are [Music]
yeah we're about to get our first song it's
coming up here soon let's do it are you okay
doesn't even hear me I'm just not like him
I don't see things the way he does now you're
just as stubborn in some ways this is what
I'm here for let's go let's go
isn't it neat you bet wouldn't you think my
collection never it's never complete wouldn't
you think I'm the girl the girl who has everything
you are the King's Daughter so yes
how many wonders can one Cavern hold you could
fit more in there sure she's got everything
I've got gadgets and gizmos are plenty I've
got a who's that said what's its Galore her
voice is incredible
I want my
nipple chills man I wanna see wanna see him
dancing walking around
oh fear gross
God the pipes on her to explore that you're
above us
oh there's like Goosebumps I don't know there's
so much emotion behind this [Music]
that's phenomenal man that was amazing tear
it up a little bit dude
because she's not just hitting like the notes
like she's really capturing the actual emotions
yeah that desperate wanting oh no no no what
does she think she doing
surface oh
she just at the Disneyland show
Mickey Mouse is on that though yeah Ariel
[Music]
oh no how'd she get up there upper body strength
apparently Jesus she does upper body dates
every day she's got water weights under there
this time you separated yourself from the
rest of the crew these peasants are more becoming
of a future king you mean be more like my
father was cut off from the rest of the world
I relate with this guy 21 years ago the king
and queen took you in and treated you as one
of their own so he's not an actual Heir is
that what's Happening Here it's a kind of
leader that's the whole reason we're on this
voice don't you see we have to stay open to
what's out here that's the only way our Island
can grow I want to make England Great again
how do they not see her shiny fins how she
not flopping around like a fish does when
they're out of water for a while
damn that hit quick didn't it I do like how
they have enhanced the grittiness I guess
of the Sailor life feels like Pirates of the
Caribbean I think it works really well live
action-wise actually yeah
I would have completely panicked and given
up at this point yeah yeah we're dead
that guy's dead [Music]
oh no we need water [Music]
I am a sucker for something that feels like
it's on a Sound Stage I do like it the vibe
of that hug [Music]
second I saw someone stopped to save a dog
me too
[Music]
I'm so confused me what I thought that was
happening in the movie
you get knocked out is that what happened
when his head bashed against the I want this
movie to subvert expectations she shouldn't
bomb him oh my God the dark Little Mermaid
here
well they look good together they do she's
more like her dad than she realizes that's
the whole point of the movie I'm talking about
the interracial love oh my gosh
get off me you fool oh hey didn't expect to
find you here the king can never hear this
why would she talk to the king I'm going to
forget this ever happened are you listening
to me yes sir
that was funny what would I do just
smiling at me I can't get over your interracial
love joke
[Music]
why do they
have torches it's not dark out nah maybe they
were searching through the night he's alive
I let the queen [Music] I I got my eyes on
you you just want to turn everything into
like a horror movie so creepy suck text happening
I don't know how but I know something's starting
right now you tell me this is a bit of a horror
movie [Music] here we go
beautiful
in love with the human world and now she found
her soul mate
finally the power away from Triton that should
have been mine all alone why should it have
been hers looks a little bit like cosplay
I think she's doing a great job but I feel
like her makeup animated did you see Ursula
in the film and yeah but no one else looks
like cosplay but she kind of looks a little
bit like I think she's doing a great performance
she had like super heavy makeup in the film
in the animated film I agree I can still feel
they could be both you're wrong and I'm right
swear that's where you sign up for oh yeah
tie the knot
this obsession with humans
maybe crusty Sebastian if you had just seen
it up there the ship rode on the wind and
they filled the sky with fire okay okay listen
to me [Music] better than anything they got
going on up there yep let's hear this sweet
is always greener in somebody else's League
oh Shame about going up there but that is
a big mistake right here on the ocean floor
wonderful things surround you what more is
your
[Music]
the place under the sea oh how beautiful that's
cool nobody beat us and eat us oh
[Music] so they can touch the jellyfish I
feel like this is the first time I'm really
paying attention to the lyrics I didn't realize
they say fry has to feed us that's why I was
like I've sung along with this but I don't
think I caught that contest
oh so cute that's more like the size of flounder
oh look how cute look at them like little
flubbers yeah [Music] oh that's really cool
do you think her holding on to them like that
is hurting them though that's what I was wondering
earlier
know how to jam here very beautiful they all
gathered to teach Ariel I was gonna say they've
been missing for a lot of this movie but suddenly
we
she was real she saved my life have you checked
the neighboring Islands not all of them then
I will no you will not I hope there's a line
in there like you remind me of my mother only
you say that only during our vows oh God shipwrecks
hurricanes the Sea Gods are against us how
many times do I have to oh he was adopted
I forgot yeah may I remind you that a deadly
shipwreck first brought you to us and now
I almost lost you to one the other day shipwreck
brings you a baby brings you love so they
all in this film like are under this heavy
belief that there are Gods under the ocean
it's okay Eric I wonder if they give him a
song He's not Harry Styles so I doubt it I'm
waiting for the new song I think if Harry
Styles it took him soon let's hear this now
all I am is haunted it's days and hours Rojo
by all I ever think about is you in these
wild uncharted waters come find me you deep
Eric you deep [Music] a siren [Music] this
guy has been singing since we were not sure
jeez we've been sailing for hours
my God damn
these two have Odes extremely passionate love
for each other I am wasn't she blurry when
he saw her so he doesn't really know what
she looks like that's the whole point of but
the reality is stuck in his head nobody mentioned
her eyes you saw a little bit of her eyes
what color are my eyes gray there are some
type of green brownish blue thing it will
take thousands of years for this Coral to
grow back and they've killed nearly all of
this I've never even seen one you were just
a child when mother died and father stopped
there they all have the same mother they all
have the same mother I don't understand how
the reproduction of the children have you
noticed that Ariel has been acting peculiar
lately I know you've been keeping something
from it keeping something is my little one
in love oh I tried to stop us I tried to stop
her from going to the service I started to
stay away from humans oh no Sebastian he got
scared he was scared you went to the above
World there was a shipwreck a man was drowning
I had to save him you should have let him
Drown Your savages savages savages and even
humans
Eric had nothing to do with it Eric you know
his you would have just heard him father he's
he's passionate and kind he's a human you're
a mermaid yes but that doesn't make us enemies
promise me we'll never look for him again
damn these are like real ass performances
oh man you really feel the emotion much more
like action
leave again I feel like in the animated that
scene was more impactful for some reason her
reaction like the facial expressions is like
this is way more because of the tangibility
because it's real life yeah [Music]
I mean the one part as a viewer that I'm having
a hard time working passes I'm I was more
used to trying being like someone I was like
he's scary and he's not really scary here
he seems more father-like here yeah yeah he's
more compassionate and yeah he's a little
softer yeah my mind's just readjusting
I'm your auntie Ursula the sea witch the what
Sunday morning
whatever you say darling darling wait yes
[Music] careful whoa there's like prehistoric
stuff Happening Here same at all like father
described you he always got what he wanted
and what did I get nothing I know what you're
going to believe me I know why you're here
I really like her yeah she's doing great and
you're so young don't you see you're meant
for each other you suffer like this love the
theatrical tortured performance she's doing
great you can't live in that world unless
you become a human yourself
did the whole performance it's not even possible
it's what I do that's what I live that's what
I live for I admit that in the past I've been
a nasty I've landed all my ways repentance
in the light and let us switch through yes
fortunately she's a little magic into magic
and you lately please don't laugh I use it
on behalf of the miserable lonely and depressed
pathetic [Music] this one Longing To Be thinner
that one wants to give the girl and do I help
him yes indeed I was not expecting her to
be this good I wasn't either I'll whip up
a little potion to make you human for three
days I would sleep all three of those before
the sun sets on the third day you and princy
must share a kiss you will remain human permanently
but a few jokes you'll turn back into a mermaid
give up the whole sea life give up your mermaid
gifts you won't have the stereos hanging around
dragging you down you won't be able to breathe
in the water who needs it I really think she's
one of the best performances so far you'll
no longer have that Sirens song so it is like
a siren I'll keep it safe and soundness here
with me we got a deal I don't know I mean
I'll just give you the premium package kid
I mean they're they're both like really great
in this movie [Music]
damn that is visually stunning
just your voice volume and your soul
to me
[Applause]
[Music] this thing terrified me when I was
a kid this is pretty terrifying yeah I don't
know how she was like
[Music] I was gonna say she just drowns and
dies
[Music]
it's interesting that she knew to use her
feet well isn't it the same way a tail works
I guess he was like well you still have to
kind of like feed her well don't say motion
essentially right let me go after the mermaid
I know she doesn't stand a chance without
this a mermaid without a voice you know what
they cut out the alt-right um fear Monger
body language which is like how can I get
him when they're like you have your looks
your pretty face they cut that out she won't
remember she needs to get I don't know why
I like that part it's just a matter of time
I feel like Melissa McCarthy like there's
something in her performance of her eyes where
she's she's not overly animated here that
makes like she keeps it really cold here it's
like a perfect pitch for the performance
girl are you all right I'll go find something
to cover you up
I need I need to close up our feet here okay
I'll take you to the castle they'll know what
to do with you there come on
it's gonna get cooked oh yeah the chef's in
well they cut them up that weird little shop
with a little Thin Mustache this feels different
really seen like the Caribbean fisherman life
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about having this
song kind of loses the effect that she's supposed
to feel like she doesn't have a voice she'll
survive but she's been through it I wonder
what happened to her dear look it's a fire
it's warm and it glows and it lights this
chamber I actually like it because I feel
like this is how she would behave these are
things she's all wanted to see but I think
we could have done it without a song then
how will we know what she's thinking
come on Ariel time to stop there you go all
of your poor girl you must be starving Rosa
get us for a child some food everyone's so
sympathetic to her odd behaviors I know oh
adorable two shipwrecks in one week Prince
Eric's still looking for that girl who saved
him let's do your idea I'll get the prince
see they put it together because she's singing
yeah in her mind
like you know
I'm so sorry to hear what happened what's
your name she doesn't speak sire get rid of
her the woman I loved said
well we're glad you made it to us see a place
to stay you saw her whole outline right well
then you're welcome to stay here make sure
she has anything she needs and Earl you could
have swam to a very different Shore things
could have turned out very different for you
we should let you get some rest I guess the
song works on the sense of the gut punch of
the build up she's like oh he's gonna know
it's me I know God all right I'll try to help
you but we've got to be bold act quickly don't
forget about the case no no not me the prince
hello oh no she's Put a Spell on You you can't
remember can you [Music] I mean you saw her
Put A Spell On hopeless child yes I knew it
that's all I would do so she's a princess
under the sea gets shot to be human to become
a princess on life just put that together
flounder told me the whole story as Ariel
killed the Prince yet
straight face where's Ariel now what do you
mean she's right here
she moves so fast without him noticing
she's in his room doesn't even know it [Music]
well they really needed to find the actress
who could yeah who can sing to dialogue and
be able to communicate just with her eyes
like Expressions so well nobody usually comes
in here
my Little Mermaid oh so cute he said the title
of the Moon
I never believed all that law about mermaids
luring Sailors to their deaths oh really I
want you to have her nearly all of these things
come from my voyages you're both Hoarders
perfect you believe that such amazing things
exist down there no wait
he knows even more oh that's smart that's
smart I don't remember if that's in the anime
movie or not regardless that is smart there's
loads of them at this time of year had no
idea you could do that oh me no that's really
clever is this the anime movie I remember
how do I yeah that's it that's it
[Music] I'll work on that I love the people
there oh we've been together for hours it's
so cute yeah she's just been listening to
him talk the whole time so funny you're the
perfect woman
you listen so wow and then all of that is
Rainforest I could show you around all right
we'll go tomorrow but so oh Grimsby good may
I have a quiet word sir quiet word it's interesting
how they've made Grimms be a bit of a Grimmer
I like he's a bit of a not an antagonist but
an obstacle or something like that you know
we were going to send out all the characters
tomorrow to look for the girl of course yes
we must do that what your mother said yesterday
about you not leaving the castle until you're
feeling better I feel fine it feels fine Grimsby
we gotta do this I suppose we could spare
one Carriage ah never mind this one I thought
Grimsby was about this was smooth you just
cursed sorry use the curse word [Music]
are we not going to get a scene of the the
cooking oh you're right I guess so we're running
low on time for that young lady
I think you'll be needing this hey is that
the original uh Ariel is it uh what's her
name Amy Ashley I don't know [Laughter] [Applause]
[Music]
oh look at Eric culturally acquainted with
his people you'll see the eyes of a screech
out up in the tree hey hey
[Music] my oh my I think it's time for a little
vocal romantic stimulation please know
nah man we got to be sneaky about this using
the power of suggestion how are we gonna do
that we've got to blend in with the sounds
of nature so she doesn't hear us they really
done flounder dirty a lot of character really
[Music] words she don't got a lot to say but
there's something about her crap [Laughter]
the time is right and the time is tonight
go on and kisses
Jungle Cruise [Music]
[Music] [Laughter] Catherine no definitely
not Catherine
Aries close Aries [Music]
[Laughter] that was clever I like that that
was really cute that's a beautiful leg Written
in the Stars oh
so cute together kiss my girl foreign
[Music]
look at him Slither away
it's not fair Ursula it's time Ursula took
matters into her own sense oh here we go oh
yeah I wonder what she's gonna look like
oh [Laughter] that prince won't know the most
Melissa McCarthy moment she's not in this
water look again shirts all of a sudden says
if you have to Ariel wouldn't dare go above
no idea why would she leave never mind that
just find her uh did you guys don't need to
know why should we continue the search I feel
a little if you want the advice of an old
man don't be held back by what you think should
be I think only of what is I'm still single
Eric why would I listen to you [Music] dilemma
Eric do I hold out for that one person who
I saw a blurry moment of or this one I've
had a connection with all day with it's hard
choices man the scales what if the other one's
hotter
[Music] whoa damn Melissa McCarthy you really
did a lot for this
who is that actress I don't know she's beautiful
that is a hard competition now man wake up
wake up wake up wake up once I know who wrote
this song then I can fly in here for you to
see and hear what I found oh my God is this
100 to the rhythm of this yeah
he wants to you know when humans oh man they're
Penguins throw rice for the pigeons they're
trying to blow up the pigeons
so we can't slow down
thank you thank you either you and I feel
very different about that not into that song
I thought it was fun right the surprise Eric
but I do owe her my life this evening you
shall introduce your intended to the court
if it's really what you want Eric what I want
um it's what we both want lovely indeed okay
so he is like Enchanted under a spell right
now look at the movie didn't make it clear
if they were doing that the voice also has
like a siren hold on them Ariel [Laughter]
[Music]
the girl that cast doesn't look evil I remember
in the animated movie I know yeah [Music]
how do you cast a girl that looks evil she's
a green I know a few
[Music]
it's like living in a reality show Ariel I'm
sorry I know it was her but it wasn't
she's she's funny see which in Disguise yes
yo gold flounder go tell the Sea King what's
happening oh oh no when I give these signal
you dropped me got it got it guess I'm on
my own
oh Eric it's beautiful [Applause] has anybody
seen the ring [Music] yes scrimsby
right kill her Peck her face
[Music]
oh I kind of feel like they rushed to this
one I mean yeah I think we're trying to get
to the climax here oh you want to see more
of a girl fight no I just be like a total
because I move a little fast through it [Music]
oh yeah they're real Ariel I see you all alone
I should have known I don't know what came
on for me get away from her whoa that was
kind of scary [Music]
oh okay she plays Evil well
she belongs to me now
blood it's unbreakable I want to see you suffer
for unfortunate soul unfortunate soul
[Music]
wow
so all of his powers in the
oh my God it's turning into The Little Mermaid
tiny things yeah a little worm [Music] s
how did we get so far down [Music]
oh oh my they didn't deserve that
she's misunderstood there's two sides for
every story
holy moly they did it this feels a lot of
crafting [Music]
oh they were in her hair
oh my
God damn that's pretty terrify that was great
[Music]
she's really doubling down to kill these two
[Music] oh my
what is she doing she helped guide the boat
I was thinking is it did she push it up and
how I I don't know
he's not even gonna try to jump out of the
way
oh
damn Ursula your response time is really slow
basketball players are slow
she's like giant size there's a difference
okay
Daddy trident's back I didn't fight alone
father Eric was with me well done letters
knows that you're safe on a home where you
belong you can at least get Eric to shore
oh Eric's gonna do it all down yeah [Laughter]
actually after a fantasy guy no I was wrong
she was very real and so were your feelings
for her I see that now it's just that I really
like this to freaking Edition to be together
I actually really like almost everything that's
been added
Eric's buried someone else he's got children
she's a real abandoned [Laughter]
it was weird about sure he doesn't have the
blurring effect as the water provides then
there's just one problem left
thank you [Music] oh he's crying yeah it's
pretty sad
[Music] oh
Ah that's some touch and crap right there
[Music] speed [Applause] wait till they meet
your father-in-law
the old marriage marks A New Beginning for
us the beginning the royalty trades we can
conduct later on something you almost lost
where where is it you're sitting on it bird
oh keep it from me I hope she causes you less
trouble than I did you won't be gone too long
were you Ariel oh that's right she loses her
best friend [Music]
to give up your remorse to be heard well now
I am listening and I will always be here for
you
[Music] damn that cut one
where's that crazy guy has been destroyed
[Music] it was perfect [Laughter]
yep there you go new lyrics by new lyrics
by all right
okay okay you know what I was thinking about
me we kind of like we commented a lot during
the movie what I was thinking though of what
I why I liked Haley Bailey's performance so
much especially underwater is when she interacts
with the other animals is there another word
for underwater animals uh
sea life when she interacts with the sea life
it feels like she's really interacting with
another character she's not just like hey
I'm pretending like I'm talking to a green
screen thing right now we're a tennis ball
it really seems like she's she's having a
real scene so that there's like a genuineness
to it and I thought I thought she was uh I
thought she was perfect what did you think
I thought I think all the characters are perfect
honestly I don't think anyone was like miscast
or didn't fit their roles um yeah I really
loved her performance her emotion behind a
lot of the songs I feel was something that
isn't really portrayed in something animated
because you don't get that emotion on a face
um and even Javier verdem's performance I
feel like I buy the father-daughter role here
I'm more connected to it even though I don't
have a relationship with my dad a more emotionally
connected to it than in the animated film
I think all the relationships are fleshed
out better here than in the animated film
that's fair that's it's also what much longer
than the animated film now right yeah I had
more time I mean I'm taking this off look
guys I know you I know people say there's
there's always those inevitable comments where
people someone's gonna come in and be like
you should just look at it on its own without
comparing to the animated movie but that's
impossible that's a big ask that you were
asking of someone to like completely limited
something you've watched repetitively throughout
your childhood and look at this stable of
your child when they have like adapted certain
so much of it like scene to scene it's impossible
to do that I don't think this replaces the
animated film I feel like if I ever have a
child I I show them the animated film first
before I show them this because I am so deeply
connected to the animated film from my childhood
uh-huh um I I it's you're gonna get the comparisons
you can't look at it as it's on it's the same
story it's the same story there's a lot of
his Shopper shots
because they're they're adapting the animated
movie Jody Benson that's the original Ariel
and I just saw her okay I kept saying Amy
or Ashley Jody Benson I I I agree I think
there's there I was the thing that surprised
me was there are some things that I I actually
thought they did better like with certain
relationships I do think it's still a little
too long am I I think it's a little like it
goes on a little too long there's when he's
out by the Sea and I thought he was looking
at Vanessa that's when I started feeling the
length at one point I almost like June said
I feel like this is running a little bit Yeah
it goes a little too long and uh I I don't
and while I find like Sebastian cute and like
I think the designs of them are cute and I
and Aquafina surprised me I'm see there's
something about Aquafina where every time
she shows up in something I like her a lot
but for some reason my initial uh preconceived
a hater for some reason but every time she
shows up at anything I'm always like she's
great and this is another case of that where
I'm like I I don't know why I doubt that I'm
going to enjoy her performances because yeah
I thought she was excellent I like how she
she played her more aloof than uh even the
animated version I still the thing is I with
the animated version I prefer the it's kind
of horrible because it's an animated movie
and it and again this is my first time watching
this movie versus repetitively watching the
animated movie the the the animal the the
sea life and the animals are I like significantly
more in the animated version and uh like like
Sebastian in him in as a character or Sebastian
I like more I feel more of that energy interesting
I like Sebastian better here but for you yeah
what that shocks me I prefer flounder in the
animated film he's more oh a thousand percent
I don't think there's there's no disputing
that and I prefer Scuttle if you prefer if
you prefer floundery in these than this I
don't I have no idea I can't even see an argument
for that yeah because he's like that relationship
feels almost non-existent here I feel like
Sebastian has more um relatable qualities
here than the animated crap how well do you
remember Sebastian because I remember Sebastian
he's more of like um from how I remember it
you've seen the movie the animated film more
recently than I have I mean I've known it
really well and then I saw it a few months
ago yeah before the one of the trailers yeah
yeah um whereas I I remember Sebastian being
kind of like really staunch on the rules like
uh don't do this he was kind of more he wasn't
as lenient as the Sebastian here if that makes
sense that's what I remember I think I think
I still have more of a connect because of
the fact that it's animated they allow more
expression and teeth and stuff and I thought
he was really funny in the animated so yeah
I still I think my because yeah I mean he's
significantly more fresh and he's kind of
like an iconic side character yeah well they've
cut out one of the most iconic scenes from
the film with Sebastian which was the chef
scene yeah yeah so I I have I have that preference
there and I'm just getting the comparison
stuff out of the way and uh yeah I mean like
there's not dude it's it's tough because it's
such a different medium that I there's there
feels like just because of the nature of what
we do that you have to pick but I I'm not
no I I I there I just go this one's different
and then here's what I like and here's what
I don't like I I like I was surprised by how
much I actually enjoyed this because I love
the first trailer and the second trailer I
did not like and then this TR this movie was
Oh this is actually really enjoyable take
the animated film out of it this on its own
Standalone is a good film they do manage to
make it their own as well without it just
being one of those only solely just a one-to-one
adaptation that they I thought they added
enough and then the way they adapted the the
sequences that were directly from the animated
movie I feel like they did add their own flavor
around it and the performances didn't feel
just derivative of them like trying to copy
paste yeah I think Javier Bardem especially
does a very different Trident um and a Haley
Bailey Triton Trident I've been saying Trident
my whole life
for the same name
yeah because you know it the the Regal qualities
of of the animated version are like you know
and and every time he's on screen and there's
there's more of a of a Pizzazz or something
to the to the because it's animated they could
do a lot more with a limited with a limited
run time where here they needed stuff to breathe
more to get the believability down you know
like all those scenes that are added between
Eric and Ariel uh I feel like are necessary
to them like I buy into their relationship
much more whereas an animated film that quick
fall in love thing is more believable in an
animated film than it is in a live action
film yes but because of the run time the excitement
and the the Peril of the stuff in the finale
actually to me yeah it feels a little bit
diluted I agree here because it even even
though the anime movie is like significantly
shorter when Ursula takes over uh in the human
form I feel like for some reason in the anime
movie The it probably doesn't but it feels
like it it lasts longer and it feels like
it's just such an impact where here it felt
like she took over for like five minutes like
10 minutes you know and then you don't even
see the impact really Triton what disappears
but he's not turned into like the little worm
we don't see him in like the cage and and
you know his struggle there it's a real real
quick turn around where he's suddenly back
again yeah exactly and and it's and like I
said in the animated movie I mean it's if
for all for all we know it's probably the
same amount of run time but the effect still
manages to have much more of an impact and
a punch because of that movie's shorter run
time and the energy and the pacing how much
they could do a lot more with a little run
time because animated they can rely more on
the emotion being conveyed with visual expression
uh than than here so yeah because of the way
this movie's paced by the time you get to
these parts that actually feels rushed and
and the the weight of it feels like kind of
kind of dimmed down um because it's like they
were barely he was barely if you're here because
of the run time it feels like Trident was
barely gone you know he's gone for like a
few minutes his sacrifice only lasted a few
minutes yeah um Ursula taking over in the
human form was only a few minutes where before
it was like wow it really feels like All Is
Lost in Ariel can't conquer this so yeah they
did feel rushed there and the but but really
you know um I was surprised by how much I
really loved the the relationships everyone
I do actually I gotta say like I I I like
I think I like Ariel and Eric here more you
know I love the cartoony performance of Eric
that classic classic Prince yeah the classic
Charming Prince but their relationship here
was significantly more nuanced and I have
to say as someone who I feel like Disney movies
and a lot of animated films are trying to
take out that how do I order this I'm trying
to take out that romance Factor where oh the
woman only cares about falling in love and
true love's kiss I actually like that they
really leaned heavy into the romance Factor
here and that they are true love and and gave
and meant to be instead of um like oh she
figures it out on her own and didn't need
Eric to kind of save the day type of deal
I agree well in the animated movie you know
it's it kind of is like they're both just
so freaking perfectly hot and look at him
and they look at her they fall in love yeah
we're here you watch the relationship develop
yeah and you really get to see how without
I mean he gets to communicate but through
but there's ways of where the communication
is obviously um uh limited but you still get
to see how they get a bond with each other
you know the words are limited the interactions
the body language and the the facial expressions
are so deeper here yeah I think for the human
for the I think yeah for the adaptation of
the human stuff a lot of that works better
yeah um and that's gonna be I mean it's pretty
normal yeah and so and it had it but reason
like other than like the last half hour where
I thought the pacing was kind of like dipping
a little bit I feel like the movie was actually
paced really well yeah um it was really fun
like I If we have a counter here because we're
recording a bunch of equipment stuff and then
by the time I got to the airport I was like
oh wow we're an hour like I didn't realize
how much time had gone by and and I normally
if I see that counter I'm I'm like man we
still got this much time to go that's the
only time I looked down at it is for that
scene I was telling you that I started feeling
it felt like it was running long and I looked
down I was like oh well okay yeah that was
like it was after two hours at that point
but I was like that's when I felt the length
of the film and the visuals is I like what
they did here more than the choice with Lion
King where they went just like a photo completely
photorealistic in Lion King they I thought
they had a decent splice of animated meets
photorealistic you know allowing for Sebastian
to be more expressive with his eyes at least
and scutler Scuttle and flanham terrible names
you know this I know and I've flounder just
watch them I still will butcher it I promise
I will still call her Arya and um yeah I thought
all that was really rock solid and the musical
number what do you think of the musical I
mean the actual music numbers were as great
as always I think Haley Bailey's voice is
absolutely phenomenalized we've clearly stated
while watching this but the new ones I don't
feel a lot of them I don't feel unnecessary
except for Ariels I feel like all of her new
ones are fairly necessary but like I don't
care about Prince Eric's singing part really
I don't um and I didn't like the scuttlebutt
song because it's just so with the tone of
the movie and the other songs that are in
the movie even the newer songs it was super
out of place to me so it kind of took me out
of it a little bit
all right and I'm like of course you're gonna
have Aquafina I can't I can't I cannot disagree
with you because you're scared all I'll say
is no I don't say I was just like I don't
know like this is so odd and it feels it feels
a little out of place but I don't know for
some reason I'm enjoying I think it's just
because I like my mom all Miranda and I think
Disney obviously loves the Manuel Miranda
honestly hey Lynn we got a new movie you want
to do it again and do that no problem when
it when the song comes on and you're like
this is obviously lin-manuel Miranda song
it should organically Fitness it took a few
sentences to be like this sounds exactly like
what Le Manuel Miranda does yeah every single
time um yeah I know it didn't feel like it's
most inventive one I I still yeah I mean I'm
a bit I have a bit of a dichotomy when it
comes to the uh the one with her inner voice
singing stuff because you like the scuttlebutt
song yeah color would be weird uh I like the
I don't know I like the I like this song itself
that's the thing is I like the song itself
I think though for the context of the movie
I I really it pulls me out because I want
to just be in the perspective of she cannot
speak but
but I had some vocal cord malfunction right
now I know what I sound like I know what I
sound like and I think my thoughts in my voice
of course no I get what you're saying like
I think there's an argument to be made like
we were saying of how you can still justify
it and and I totally see the choice for that
to me though it I just I feel like the impact
is not as strong the that's my opinion and
you know you have your payments I'm sure most
people probably agree with you you'd be surprised
especially with your audience uh the Eric
song was uh yeah I was like I feel like I
couldn't just use dialogue here yeah I didn't
like it I don't think we needed that I didn't
think we needed a whole song he's got a nice
voice um I don't think we need a whole song
though and I yeah I like Derek's performance
a lot and I think they made him a little bit
more you know he's a lot more swashbuckling
in the animated movie and here he's more of
a relatable guy and I thought to also make
them their his backstory somehow be relatable
I feel so sorry for this princess
poor Guys these royalty struggles huh but
I love the but I thought they made it um just
to make their backgrounds find a way to truly
find a common ground and similarities where
they could identify with each other I thought
was really strong the addition of the mom
I thought was great uh as well I like it I
also like I feel like it's such a Trope a
cliche of our worlds don't belong oh it's
just such a Trope it was just such a cliche
decision to go with but it doesn't take me
out of the film yeah something I would like
to see not be the fallback for a lot of films
which I feel like it is I think the anime
movie is like a solid tight film like I say
only 80 minutes long that's so the animated
one who's is this um it's Tara Roxy's one
of them they leave [__] all the time Tara
Roxy we're gonna have a discussion tonight
um then there's that what's the other someone
Miss Melissa McCarthy she disappears totally
at the end too though like she's defeated
and you don't really see that's the Adam made
a movie well I feel like there should be some
impact from what she's done you know but especially
with the long run time you have you could
have included something and I'm so used to
Disney now the these days humanizing their
villains a little more like what they did
with um Maleficent you know they tend to try
to humanize to make you feel a little bit
more they don't do that at all here with Ursula
no I I thought to keep her though the animated
one I think Melissa McCarthy really saves
it because she managed to because I thought
it would be the most cartoony performance
and it already really is out of the universe
like it is um it's the yet she the most can't
be out of all of them yeah she still managed
to not pull like I didn't get pulled out by
her I got more pulled in because of her she's
super engaging yeah because I thought she
was going to be like way too animated doing
her in her expressions and stuff I thought
she was gonna overdo it and I thought she
was gonna bring too much of that Melissa because
when we heard she was catch you're like of
course of course Melissa McCarthy's planners
like it was just like the most obvious casting
and despite it being obvious casting she still
managed to honor the animated version and
really bring her unstable to it and she there's
something really unique um I got a letter
in Tara yeah I can let her in from the my
phone all right do it yo we're letting you
in you we're gonna tell you when it's unlocked
is it unlocked oh yeah it's come on in we're
just filming this thing we could just stand
up to go get you we need to determine if this
hair clip is yours that's leaving behind little
hair clips watch the swearing
okay there's rocks which is our detective
advice and narrowed it down now she leaves
like cups people always leave crap behind
Coy left a shirt why is he sure yeah right
there's something about her ex I kept I couldn't
quite pinpoint it like she kept this like
cold stare like a mouth above and and didn't
emote much here which I thought weirdly grounded
the performance in this large makeup helps
with that though yeah it was like she got
overly botoxed or something and that she couldn't
emote or something but it worked it it helped
it it plays to that like um uh what is that
the word for like that person who's that old-time
Starlet who like used to be used to be the
successful Hollywood Starlet and then they're
now like I'm ready for my close-upness yeah
she's like that kind of character golden Hollywood
actress yeah exactly a faded star and that's
the kind of performance that she leaned into
here which I thought was so excellent um yeah
that was perfect uh yeah visual effects were
good I love this movie I think it's really
good I think it's fun I liked it a lot we
do I love it yeah okay I mean yeah that's
a good movie I'd watch it again yeah I would
too we own it now so yeah you can watch it
whatever you want good way to Disney plus
but that's fine nope not for them I would
buy it and I I gotta say too yeah like uh
for the last thing I'll say intentionally
with everything going on that this is the
like oftentimes these live action remakes
get a lot of crap for just the like just like
essentially just aping the script that came
before and I think that for an adaptation
script they did a really great job here uh
to it to adapt it I thought the writing actually
did a really surprisingly good job a lot of
times you just feel like hack jobs and this
did not feel that way to me that was good
acting's good so I got paid them fairly mother
effers anywho you done yeah you guys want
to buy a cat not this one not these but there's
uh I mean they don't have to buy right is
it is it a buy adoption fee yeah adoption
fee yeah what people can just get free cash
and feed them to their dogs or their snakes
so who feeds cats that are dogs people do
that yes they use them as like bait for like
fighting dogs yeah that's horrible yeah all
right guys well we're gonna watch Avatar the
way of water and Aquaman now all right we'll
talk with you guys soon thank you so much
for being here [Music]